et bien cette participation a été
extrêmement importante pour la première
série qui commençait ses compositions à
8h15
le pourcentage est de 93 et demi pour
cent c'est très satisfaisant car en
période normale
les chiffres ne sont jamais supérieurs
mais c'est le baiia vous avez reçu la
visite du ministre éducation nationale
quel était le but de cette visite en
iran et deuxièmement elle était connue
des étudiants et quel impact cela dure
et bien personnellement j'ai été touchée
de la visite de monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et je pense que sa
présence montre son ferme désir de voir
reprendre une vie universitaire normale
est de voir se dérouler les examens
d'une façon normale qui soit
inattaquable et qui d'autre part permet
de rassurer les étudiants sur la suite
des épreuves qu'ils ont assumée